Salut, ça va être la première vidéo sur internet
où l'on va citer plus de 10 marques
alors qu'il n'y a pas de placement de produit
Alors là, il y a 2 solutions :
ou c'est super intéressant
ou je suis le roi des imbéciles
Je vous laisse faire votre opinion là dessus
mais je vais pas ouvrir de sondage pour ça
j'aurai un peu trop peur de la réponse
L'année dernière, j'ai écrit quelque chose pour mon spectacle dont je ne me suis pas servi
et je suis retombé sur ces notes récemment
je me suis dit "ce serait dommage de ne pas s'en servir"
donc je vous fais une vidéo là dessus
Sur le sens caché des logos des marques
on les voit tout les jours, on les a tout le temps sous notre nez
et pourtant on ne sait pas toujours ce qu'il y a de caché à l'intérieur
ou pourquoi ils ont été fait comme ça
et puis quand à un moment donné tu comprends,
tu fais: "Ho mais Oui,
mais c'est évident pourtant"
La première fois que j'ai eu cette révélation c'est quand je me suis rendu compte
du slogan: "Lapeyre y'en a pas 2"
Lapeyre y'en a pas 2
Là c'est sûr vous me trouvez débile
mais moi j'ai mis des années à me rendre compte
que Lapeyre c'était une paire et qu'il y en a pas 2
Je ne sais pas si je dois continuer cette vidéo après cette révélation
Je sais que certain d'entre vous, l'année dernière, ont eu aussi cette toute petite révélation
quand ils se sont aperçus que la menthe à l'eau qu'il y avait dans le générique
Une menthe à l'eau ça fait
Mentalo. M-E-N-T-A-L-O
Donc aujourd'hui je vous parle de 10 marques
ou de 10 logos de marque
dont certains dont vous connaissez peut-être le sens
mais tous ça m'étonnerait
Le 1er dont je vous parle c'est FedEx
FedEx c'est un service de livraison
un petit peu comme UPS ou ce genre de chose
et comme tout service de livraison on part d'un point pour aller à un autre point
ce que vous n'avez peut être pas vu dans le logo, c'est qu'ils ont caché une flèche à l’intérieur du logo
qui symbolise le transport et le côté "on y va c'est rapide"
Et bien juste là vous devriez le voir maintenant, c'est entre le E et le X de FedEx
dans le Ex de expédition
on a la flèche
Le deuxième vous l'avez peut être déjà vu par contre
c'est le logo de Toblerone
vous savez il y a une montagne, déjà c'est pas n'importe quelle montagne
mais à l'intérieur de la montagne, il y a un ours
Si vous ne l'aviez pas vu maintenant vous voyez l'ours, c'est sûr.
Cet ours là, spécifiquement, c'est le symbole d'une ville
de la ville de Berne
Et Berne on retrouve les lettres dans Toblerone
dans le bonne ordre, on retrouve Berne dans Toblerone
donc déjà Berne est caché dans Toblerone
et l'ours qui est caché dans la montagne qui est le symbole de la ville de Berne
est un hommage qu'a voulu faire la créatrice du Toblerone
puisqu'elle est originaire de cette ville
Le troisième qu'on connait bien si on vient d'Ile de France
C'est le logo de la RATP
le logo de la RATP on le voit tout le temps, c'est un cercle avec un visage à l'intérieur
mais est ce que c'est pas plus que ça ?
ça fait partie des logos vraiment que j'aime bien
et que j'ai pu découvrir par moi même
ça veut dire qu'un jour j'étais dans le métro et j'ai fait "Bien sûr... mais c'est ça'
Tout simplement le cercle représente la ville de Paris
et le visage avec ce cour comme ça bleu représente la Seine
c'est ni plus, ni moins qu'un schéma, très schématisé évidemment,
de la ville de Paris et de la Seine qui le traverse
Pour le 4ème,
on s'attaque à un classique.
C'est à dire que là parmi vous il y en a plein qui vont faire
"Mais moi je connais tellement ça"
qu'ils vont vouloir aller dans les commentaires pour hurler qu'ils connaissaient déjà
et il y en a qu'y vont le découvrir pour la 1ère fois
et souvenez vous, si vous le connaissez, la 1ère fois qu'on te le fait voir tu fais
"Ah ouais"
C'est le logo Carrefour
le logo carrefour je sais pas ce que vous voyez
mais en réalité il représente simplement un "C" majuscule.
"C" étant la 1ère lettre de Carrefour évidemment.
Et ceux qu'y ne le connaissent pas sont en train de le chercher
en se disant "Ben non je vois du bleu et du rouge"
En fait, il est dessiné dans le vide
et comme il y a une disproportion des 2 couleurs utilisées, on ne le voit pas apparaître
mais si on faisait le contour, on verrait le "C" de Carrefour apparaître
ça c'est le vrai logo et c'est son vrai sens
En 5ème, je vous en ai mis 2 pour le prix d'un
En fait il y a un logo qui avait fait débat il y a quelques années quand il est sorti
le nouveau logo du TGV quand il était sorti à l'époque
on s'était aperçu de quelque chose d'amusant
moi je l'avais découvert avec Philippe Vandel sur Canal +, à l'époque il avait une chronique
Si on retourne le logo du TGV (Train à grande vitesse)
ça fait un escargot
ce qui est dommage pour un train de cette vitesse quand même
mais là apparemment soit c'est une grosse farce de graphiste,
et personne l'a vu
soit c'est quelques chose qui n'avait pas du tout était anticipé
Ce qui n'a rien à voir avec le logo de New Man
qui lui est un ambigramme volontaire
c'est à dire que New Man si on le met là et qu'on le retourne
on relit encore une fois New Man
ça c'est le genre de truc que j'adore les ambigrammes
Un 6ème, un petit plus léger
je sais pas si ça aussi vous l'aviez remarqué ou pas
mais dans les galeries Lafayette se cache une tour Eiffel
et la tour Eiffel c'est les 2 "T" de Lafayette
forcément les galeries Lafayette représentent la France donc Paris donc la Tour Eiffel
Un 7ème aussi qu'on ne m'avait pas expliqué
quand je l'ai découvert
C'est juste un jour ça m'a sauté aux yeux
Là où je suis très étonné c'est de ne jamais l'avoir vu avant
vous pouvez me dire dans les commentaires si c'était votre cas ou pas
C'est le cycliste du Tour de France
Si on regarde le logo du Tour de France,
en fait il y a un cycliste qui est caché
mais simplement à l'intérieur, ça se voit pourtant
et pourtant on le voit pas
et je pense que maintenant vous êtes en train de le voir évidemment
Ce cycliste je ne sais pas comment j'avais fait pour le rater
Pour le 8ème, on reste toujours sur une marque
c'est sur une marque que vous connaissez bien c'est Amazon
Ce qu'y me fait penser à vous dire "merci"
puisque depuis le 18 mai
je suis dans le top 3 des ventes, tout livres confondus grâce à vous
et j'ai même été un long moment premier
en vous disant "merci"
Alors sur Amazon, évidemment, on voit une espèce de sourire
c'est comme s'il y avait 2 yeux et un sourire un petit peu
mais il y a un message caché, pas tellement caché d'ailleurs
c'est que c'est une flèche qui fait rejoindre "A" et "Z"
et le message que voulait faire passer Amazon à l'époque
c'est que sur Amazon on trouve tout de A à Z
surtout qu'à l'époque c'était un petit peu plus librairie
d'où le fait de mettre le "A" et le "Z"
En 9ème, c'est pas une marque c'est un logo dont vous avez l'habitude
je vais vous faire voir le logo sur le carnet que m'avait fait une abonnée
elle me l'a fabriqué de "A" à "Z", c'est juste hyper bien fait
donc c'est le bouton power On/Off
Là vous constatez 2 choses
déjà vous constatez que ce symbole vous est familier, quotidien
et vous constatez aussi à quel point j'écris mal
puisque même ça
je ne suis pas foutu de le faire correctement
J'avais fait une vidéo où je faisais les dessins que vous m'aviez demandé
je sais plus où elle est. C'est une vidéo de 2016
mais on avait pu voir à quel point c'était horrible
Pourquoi des gens, un jour, ont décidé que ça serait le symbole On/Off
et bien pour 2 raisons : Déjà ça représente un circuit
qu'on peut ouvrir et fermer si on bascule ça
donc comme un circuit électrique
Mais il y a un deuxième sens, c'est que ce cercle représente un "O"
et ce trait représente un "1"
En clair on est sur du binaire, 0 ou 1.
Ça marche ou ça marche pas
Mon 10ème symbole
c'est un symbole qui est un peu passionnant
c'est celui du bluetooth
Alors déjà est ce que vous savez pourquoi ça s'appelle le Bluetooth?
et pourquoi c'est ce symbole là un peu bizarre?
L'ensemble de tout ça c'est un hommage à un roi danois
Le Roi Harald Blaatand
et en anglais on disait pas Harald Blaatand, on disait Harald Bluetooth
parce que vous savez on donnait souvent des petits qualificatifs au Roi
et bluetooth ça veut dire les dents bleues
en français on aurait dit "Attention voici Harald les dents bleues"
et le peuple de son pays et des autres pays l'appelaient "Les dents bleues"
parce qu’apparemment il raffolait de myrtilles,
il en mangeait à longueur de temps et ça bleuit les dents
Mais à part bouffer des myrtilles, il a fait des trucs de bien Harald!
Il a réunifié toutes les tribus danoises pour en faire un royaume
Donc il a unifié pour que tout fonctionne ensemble
Et là vous voyez un petit peu où je veux en venir!
Le système Bluetooth est fait pour que tout fonctionne ensemble en communiquant facilement
Les initiales de Harald Blaatant ou de Harald Bluetooth c'est : H.B
Et la rune Danoise pour le H c'est ça
Et la rune Danoise pour le B c'est ça
Et si on réunifie les deux, de H et B mélangés ça nous donne ça
Est-ce qu'on s'en ferait pas un petit onzième en bonus?
Parce que là clairement pour terminer le mot je voulais faire une vidéo légère
Où il n'y a pas à réfléchir, où on fait "Ah oui ça je ne savais pas!"
Donc on peut se permettre d'en faire un onzième
On va juste parler du logo de Toyota
A la base le logo de Toyota c'est censé représenter des cœurs qui vont les uns dans les autres
On peut y voir la tête d'un animal, ou encore une forme avec une corne
Mais c'est encore plus malin que ça!
Dans le logo même de Toyota, on a toute les lettres de Toyota
On a
Et celui qui a réuni toutes les idées à l'intérieur de ce simple logo basé sur quelques traits
Je trouve que c'est du génie
Et puis pour terminer je vous informe qu'il va y avoir des séances de dédicaces pour le livre
Le 24 juin à La Rochelle, le 28 juin à Caen
ça rentre au compte goutte, c'est en train de s'organiser au compte goutte
Donc à chaque fois je mets ça sur la page du site Internet
Également dans la description de la vidéo qui parle du livre
Et vous retrouverez d’ailleurs le lien de cette vidéo dans la description
Je vous tiendrai également très rapidement au courant du prochain live qu'il y aura sur la chaîne
Et en attendant je vous dis à très bientôt
Merci de vous abonner et pensez surtout à liker la vidéo
A très bientôt, Ciao!